camichel merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france alors les états unis
ont donc accusé aujourd'hui à la chine
de menacer et de harceler les
journalistes étrangers
quand les américains parlent de menaces
et de harcèlements ils font référence à
quoi très concrètement qu'est ce que
vous observez de votre côté alors tout
d'abord je voudrais apporter une
précision à ce que vous venez de dire au
sujet que deux montres en fait je suis
rétabli pochette du delf que franck mais
les textes français de mental en tv qui
est une qui est la seule télévision
prend qu'aux chinois de base et en
france en fait c'est pas une bombe et
les vidéos chinois ding prêter attention
je me trouve en chine voilà alors
actuellement je me trouve en chine pour
des raisons familiales en fait voilà
tout à fait pour des raisons familiales
je suis plus précisément dans la ville
de tianjin près de pékin
voilà alors vous pouvez répéter votre
question alors c'était quand les les
états unis donc on t'accuse aujourd'hui
la chine de menacer de harceler des
journalistes étrangers on le disait
quand les américains parlent de menaces
et de harcèlements ils font référence à
quoi très concrètement à la très content
et très complètement je n'en sais pas
plus le goût parce que ici je me trouve
avec un certain nombre de journalistes
chinois
on est dans le même hôtel parce qu'on a
pris le même avion
et comme eux il tape beaucoup plus on ne
tend pas plus que moi sur steve pâte en
chine
eh bien j'ai échangé avec eux et pas
très honnêtement on ne sait pas
donald trump chez sfr on constate sur le
terrain c'est que et à ma connaissance
la chine n'a pas menacé et harcelé les
journalistes étrangers
c'est la première chose deuxième chose
c'est une somme en compte contrairement
à ce qu'affirment les américains les
chinois n'ont pas gelé les
accréditations
non pas qu'ils touchent gelé les
accréditations des médias américains en
fait qu'il fasse et que les
accréditations sont en cours de
traitement
et pendant cette période pendant cette
attente les journalistes étrangers
peuvent continuer de travailler et de
vivre en commun ils vont peut-être que
moi je sais 1
alors cette année 2020 elle cette année
de ville val administration
l'administration trump elle aussi
déclenché les hostilités contre les
médias chinois
washington n'attribue que des visas de
90 jours aux journalistes chinois sur le
sol américain
pourquoi cette décision des états unis
pourquoi et comment est ce qu'elle est
perçue en chine bien sûr ah bon il
tenterait quand même rappeler le contact
fin alors l'utilité tout à l'heure que
en 2020 les américains vont déclencher
les hostilités contre les médias chinois
en fait en théorie dite et en contre les
médias chinois ne date pas d'hier
en fait cela remonte plus précisément en
en 2010 huit ans c'est à dire à l'époque
de la guerre commerciale
les états unis avaient traîné les pieds
pour bon d'après ma version des faits
d'après que moi je sais à l'époque déjà
les américains avaient traîné des pieds
pour renouveler les visas qu'une
trentaine de journalistes chinois et en
plus ils avaient ils allaient même
refuser les visas à certains à certains
d'entre eux c'est la première chose
deuxième chose pour revenir à cette
année en marque de trier le vent ça vous
le savez en 60 journalistes chinois ont
été contraints de plier bagage
la chine interprète je sais comme
l'expulsion qui ne dit pas son nom et en
mai les américains effectivement ont
décidé de réduire la durée de séjour des
journalistes chinois à 90 jours
honnêtement on ne comprend pas pourquoi
la seule explication c'est que tout cela
se passe sur fond sur fond de tensions
sino-américaines
d'abord ça a été de la guerre
commerciale provoqué par donald trump au
mieux c'est après tu as été de la guerre
sanitaire toujours profiter provoqué par
frein maintenant c'est la guerre on va
dire que la guerre négative idiot quelle
beauté un croc est-ce que nos envies de
provocation n'y a pas toute explication
opep s quoi et est-ce que selon vous une
normalisation des relations dans le
domaine de l'information est ce qu'elle
vous semble imaginables à court ou à
moyen terme et sous quelles conditions
c'est que les etats-unis disent
travailler sans relâche mais il est si
pour convaincre la chine de permettre
aux journalistes américains pouvoir
exercer normalement
voilà alors enfin il faut quand même que
avant de répondre avec précision à votre
question je voudrais quand même signaler
une chose c'est que si les américains
accusent les chinois tollé les médias
chinois parce que les chinois
comment qui ont gelé des accréditations
déjà c'était pas vrai ce qu'on sait de
source sûre c'est que les accréditations
sont tout ça c'est la première chose
deuxième chose c'est au nom du principe
de réciprocité que les chinois
commencent à étudier les accréditations
kuske par rapport à tout ce qui s'est
passé depuis 2010 la chine estime que
les journalistes chinois ont été
maltraités et gaye aucune raison que la
chine continue à algésiras a accosté
avec autant que ses activités
les plaques récréation journaliste
américain att qui s'est pas contre les
journalistes américains c'est juste un
diplôme acier c'est ce qu'on appelle la
pratique et réciprocité
voilà alors pour pour contrer pour
répondre à votre question avait dit je
vous en prie une normalisation des
relations un seul incident du même genre
à courir à court voilà bon je vous donne
mon point de vue personnel je pense que
et c'est possible c'est possible parce
que pour moi
si les tensions sino-américaines sont
montées d'un cran
en ce moment c'est parce qu on est à la
veille des élections américaines
donald trump et il échoue et continue de
jouer le jeu de provocation voilà un
argument politique c'est un argument
politique pour sa campagne électorale
selon vous est possible en fait un bail
très honnêtement aujourd'hui je ne vois
pas pour en quoi ça consiste en quoi ça
peut consister à un argument politique
très honnêtement je pense qu'on sait
très bien que l'un des arguments massue
pour l'emporter pour l'emporter sur son
adversaire
j'ai été critiqué en outre entre la
chine a bien sûr il va il a provoqué
cette guerre médiatique pour l'instant
je ne vois pas pourquoi si ce n'est qu'
il veut empêcher
ils voulaient empêcher les journalistes
chinois par les journalistes américains
à travailler normalement rapporter tout
ce qui va se passer au niveau des
sélections américaines je ne sais pas
sinon je ne vois pas d'autres et vous
voilà c'est la première chose deuxième
chose en tête le mot puisque on arrive
au terme de cette édition en un mot on
n'a rien en terme de santé noyon va
d'avoir une antenne d'accord semble jeu
semble probable à moyen terme
merci beaucoup camichel d'avoir répondu
à nos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes rédactrice en chef
unesco français de mandarins tv